reality couples still going strong
Jinger Duggar Volo and her husband
Jeremy the counting on stars are
expecting baby number two and giving
fans a glimpse inside their quarantine
life how are you doing in the quarantine
yeah I think everybody's just trying to
make the best of it we live in LA so for
us it provides even more opportunities
to get together with the family of her
video chat tonight season 11 premiere of
counting on was shot prior to the
pandemic Lucy were home
ginger Jeremy and nearly 2 year-old
Felicity settled into their new life in
Hollywood and their family is about to
get bigger
the couple is happily expecting their
second daughter after previously
suffering a miscarriage yeah the season
you'll follow us as we announce to my
family that I was expecting and there's
ginger and then also the sadness of
losing that little one
definitely watching that show I think
there will be a lot of emotions that
will come back up just seeing that again
but I think we're looking forward to
even the joys now having a new little
one on the way and in true Duggar
fashion ginger is not the only family
member expecting there are five girls
pregnant right now I'm excited about the
grandbabies that are coming this season
we have girls galore adult in a row so
it's amazing
[Music]